jean accueille aujourd'hui youssef
kabbaj professeur de finance au cégep de
montmorency à laval pour une raison
toute simple c'est la période de
préparation des déclarations d'impôt ici
au canada
bonjour ice glace bonjour ça va ça va
verser issue glace on va pas vous
demander de nous aider pour préparer
votre déclaration d'impôts 2020 mais on
va parler un peu d'éducation financière
on remarque beaucoup de personnes ont du
mal avec la finance personnelle parfois
faire un simple budget et le suivre pose
problème
si tu as quoi j'ai vous que l'éducation
financière homme est le parent pauvre du
système d'éducation ici au québec au
canada ou ailleurs
ouais mais je pense mais ne doit
vraiment sur la problématique je pense
vraiment à cause de l'éducation
financière est souvent on nous fait
croire que les finances c'est quelque
chose de très compliqué donc dès qu'on
parle de placement d'immobilier de
fiscalité dans place ça devient vraiment
quelque chose de deux complexes et
souvent les jambes quand c'est complexe
on veut pas s'en occuper où on veut pas
se préoccuper de ça et pourtant qu'on
prend petit à petit le le taureau par
les cornes tranquillement en fait on
comprend un peu plus le système comment
ça fonctionne et là ça on peut
l'utiliser à notre avantage ne peuvent
parler de budget ça peut être par
rapport aux crédits à la gestion du
crédit à la gestion des placements donc
tranquillement en faisant son éducation
en lisant sur le sujet mais finalement
les finances c'est pas si compliqué que
ça qu'on se donne le temps de le faire
et à partir de quel âge pensez vous
qu'il faudra commencer avec les enfants
et leur apprendre les rudiments
d'éducation financière
en fait faut commencer le plus tôt
possible donc juste des principes de
base par rapport à la consommation
souvent c'est un volet très important
des finances a les palmes donc là quand
tu reçois des revenus mais d'en mettre
systématiquement deux côtés partie v une
partie ne pas surconsommer donc de pas
forcément justement montrer aux enfants
qu'on peut acheter ce qu'on veut puis
des fois les enfants se fie beaucoup
aussi quand il voit la façon que les
parents gèrent le budget la façon que
les parents font exemple l'épicerie donc
là juste de voir le comportement et la
gestion des finances des parents est
souvent les enfants se fit là dessus
donc je pense que parent un grand rôle
est justement tranquillement d'expliquer
les concepts d'epargne de gestion du
crédit budget en tout c'est près ces
places tu ça peut commencer très jeune à
l'âge de 2-3 ans peut déjà commencer il
existe plein de livres pleins de
ressources justement là-dessus donc un
parent je pense à bordeaux 6 éduqués
pour donner une bonne éducation aux
enfants ce que je voulais revenir au
début de la discussion
est ce que c'est important de faire un
but juste une question peut-être basique
mais on voudrait bien avoir votre avis
vous enseignant en finance en fait
souvent les gens pensent en ce réflexe
là de dire je vais commencer à faire un
budget quand je vais gagner plus de
revenus ou quand j'aurai une meilleure
situation financière donc souvent votre
crise née pouvoir reporter à plus tard
parce qu'on pense que présentement le
budget on n'a pas besoin mais plus tard
quand on va avoir plus de revenus plus
d'argent à gérer on va commencer
alors que finalement la logique elle et
les verts c'est moins vous avez de
revenus puis votre situation est plus
précaire plus justement il faut prendre
le temps de le faire parce que chaque
dollar que vous gagnez il faut savoir
comment il est utilisé donc un budget
c'est tout simplement un portrait la
liste des revenus la liste des dépenses
de faire un tri là dedans mais d'avoir
un peu une idée où va notre argent
donc le faire qu'en étudiant de le faire
quand on a un revenu faible quand on a
des dettes
c'est là le plus important c'est pas
quand on va gagner plus de retenue fit
même qu'on gagne plus de revenus c'est
aussi important de le faire parce que on
veut savoir comment il est utilisé
donc finalement il n'y a pas de bon
moment pour le faire dès qu'on a le
temps faut le prendre si les gens
pensent que ça prend beaucoup de temps
mais en une heure une heure et demie
avec un beau modèle s'est fait apprécier
le mettre à jour
puis vérifiés temps en temps est ce que
en fait plus un budget une prévision de
futures donc je te vois un peu si on a
respecté un peu les grandes catégories
puis l'autre point que je voulais amener
c'est que souvent les gens à ce site
budget à la restriction
donc là on veut pas faire un budget sur
cette voie nous resterait un à faire des
choses mais en fait on peut faire un
budget et avoir un une partie qui un peu
plus variable d'une partie que qu'on va
pouvoir adapter au fur et à mesure mais
au moins d'avoir une structure de base
puis délaissé une partie variable
ça fait déjà le travail en terme de
gestion financière si vous prenez une
entreprise fut un budget un gouvernement
faible
je vois pas pourquoi un particulier qui
a moins de revenus ne ferait pas donc
donc c'est une question de gestion
financière vous avez lancé un groupe
facebook a que deux années à peu près il
est très suivi
saïd portement de l'argent ne dort
jamais que viennent chercher les gens
chez vous dans ce groupe mais en fait
une communauté facebook quand les gens
viennent là pour voir un peu ce que les
autres en viennent là pour poser leurs
questions donc souvent lorsqu'on parle
de finances on sent un peu seuls des
fois comme j'ai dit à l'heure ça peut
être complexe donc de voir un peu les
questions d autres beaucoup de gens qui
sont dans le groupe sont vraiment pas
actif mais qui ils adorent ça juste
parce qu'ils peuvent suivre les
questions et les réponses des
professionnels donc donc des fois c'est
des coups de question qu'on se pose mais
qu'on veut pas en fait
consultez on ne va pas se mettre en
action mais de voir les autres le faire
donc les gens viennent pour
principalement de l'information de
l'éducation
donc là ils veulent savoir comment
fonctionne une hypothèque tu veux savoir
dans quoi investir ils veulent savoir
comment gérer un budget commandites à
l'heure les assurances donc l'on couvre
vraiment tous les thèmes reliés à
l'argent puis les gens deviennent voir
trouver des trucs des astuces pour
pouvoir l'appliquer provenant leurs
finances personnelles
ce groupe facebook il a aussi un pont
dans sur le web qui s'appelle éduque
finance.fr et qui que vous projetez d'en
faire une application aussi pouvez-vous
nous en parler
ouais mais en fait l'idée initiale était
pas partie du groupe est parti de hoëdic
finances coincé à qui est mon idée de
lancer justement un outil parce que les
gens aussi ont besoin d'information mais
besoin d'un outil pratique donc
donc moi ce que je suis en train de
développer depuis trois ans c'est un
outil pratique donc une application
budgétaire et de gestion financière et
en parallèle à ça je trouvais que
d'abord une communauté aussi que les
gens peuvent poser les questions à tous
les jours donc en fait j'ai pu lancer
les deux projets plus ou moins en même
temps donc le projet de l'application il
va bientôt voir le jour et la communauté
elle a grossi surtout avec la pandémie
les gens avaient plus de temps les
finances
devenait encore plus important donc la
communauté elle a vraiment grossier au
fil des années au fil des deux ans et
cette communauté pourrait être de futurs
utilisateurs de l'application que vous
allez lancer j'imagine par rapport à
votre groupe là les gens viennent
chercher de l'information on est un peu
aux limites du conseil financier vous
n'êtes pas conseiller financier j'aime
ce que j'ai compris
est ce que c'est important d'avoir un
conseiller financier parce que parfois
il ya des gens qui se disent oui mais le
conseiller financier il est lié à une
banque il a des objectifs de ventes donc
elle est où il n'est pas neutre quelque
part quand ils nous offrent des choses
ouais c'est une très bonne question puis
je pense les gens sont de plus en plus
conscients de ça que justement la
personne à la banque ou dans une aide
financière ou une compagne d'assurance
nous offre des nous offre des produits
mais nous conseille en même temps donc
là ils sont un peu biaisé c'est sûr
qu'un conseiller un professionnel un peu
comme quand vous allez acheter une
voiture il vous conseille normalement
dans votre intérêt
d'où l'importance de bien éduquer pour
être sûr justement de que la personne
fait son travail comme il faut
puisqu'elle vous vend pas un peu
n'importe quoi
donc non je pense les gens viennent
c'est sûr que nous on met la limite à ce
niveau là danse on n'est pas là pour
vous refaire des conseils personnalisés
pas s'apprendre et des ventes entre ça
prend du temps pour avoir un portrait de
la situation financière de la personne
mais quand même on est capable donner
des astuces on est comme quand même
capable de donner de la formation des
expériences partager des expériences
pour pouvoir justement mieux outiller
les gens quand ils sont face à un
conseiller financier un planificateur
pour être sûr d'avoir les bons produits
pis maintenant avec l'internet et les
nouvelles applications financières là on
peut maintenant gérer nos finances par
nous mêmes donc on peut faire des
placements en ligne on peut la voir une
hypothèque en ligne vous pouvez
pratiquement maintenant tout faire en
2021 offrent pratiquement tout faire en
ligne
par contre ça prend quand même des
connaissances donc là quelqu'un qui
débute
moi je dirais de de commencer avec un
professionnel donc de se faire aider se
faire accompagner et entre temps d'être
faire son éducation lire des livres
allez sur des blogs aller sur des
groupes facebook puis tranquillement
faire son éducation pour être capable
d'être
automne entre certains aspects de la
finance une dernière question c'est par
rapport aux nouveaux arrivants aux
immigrants quand il arrive il y a une
facilité d'accès au crédit au canada
alors quand quels conseils donneriez
vous à un nouvel arrivant pour qu'ils ne
tombent pas dans le surendettement
rapidement comme ça oui c'est sûr que
dès qu'on arrive en tant qu'île migrants
déjà noté assez important d'avoir un bon
bureau de crédit parce que c'est ça qui
va vous donner accès au crédit à une
hypothèque pour acheter une voiture etc
et d'un autre côté on vous dit à mes
faut faire attention aux crédits parce
qu'on peut s'endetter et c'est donc en
fait le crédit
il est très facile d'accès au canada par
contre faut bien l'utiliser donc le faut
d'abord se renseigner sur comment avoir
un bon bureau de crédit donc les
différents facteurs que quand on regarde
mais au final ce qu'on regarde c'est
comment vous utilisez quelqu'un qui
vienne d'étrangers souvent on n'est pas
habitué aussi au concept de crédit parce
que c'est pas vraiment la même chose
donc à ce moment-là faut déjà comprendre
des produits qu'on nous aura venant que
je pense aux cartes de crédit souvent
c'est là où les jeunes ont ils pensent
que c'est de l'argent qu'on leur donne
alors que c'est de l'argent qu'on
m'emprunte donc il faut voir la carte de
crédit comme un moyen de paiement et non
comme un moyen de financement et de
l'utiliser donc d'utiliser la carte mais
de la rembourser
donc là de montrer que on est capable
d'emprunter d'utiliser le montant comme
nous prête mais qu'on a les moyens
finalement de rembourser donc donc de
faire une bonne gestion du crédit c'est
important parce que ça qu'ils vont vous
vous donnez un bond historique du crédit
et va vous ouvrir des portes plus tard
pour d'autres produits financiers
merci beaucoup et jonglage rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de finance au cégep
montmorency à laval merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
merci beaucoup ça fait plaisir